je vous disais il ya un instant 7 la
semaine prochaine s'annonce
particulièrement houleuse sur le plan
social avec un programme de défilés de
manifestations a sorti d'appel à la
grève dans les banques chez renault ou
encore dans l'enseignement
le tout sur fond de divisions syndicales
alors que la cgt ouvre demain son 42e
congrès et qu'à force ouvrière le
secrétaire général marc blondel a appelé
cet après midi je cite à une
généralisation de l'action pour le
retrait du plan juppé commentaire
yannick letranchant marc blondel très
convoité il faut dire qu'il a décidé de
lancer aujourd'hui un à revel en appel
solennel à la généralisation du
mouvement à partir de lundi
c'est une radicalisation je vais
maintenant demander pratiquement à tous
les secteurs d'activité
progressivement de rentrer dans la grève
c'est à dire de la lourde hier à partir
d'une position ça le retrait du plan
juppé
marc blondel entend bien s'installer
dans la tendance dure du mouvement
tendance qu'il partage avec louis
viannet de la cgt un mariage de raison
contre le plan de réforme de la sécurité
sociale le plan juppé cgt force ouvrière
même combat pour une même cause la grève
généralisée à tous les secteurs des
transports aux hôpitaux en passant par
les impôts etc
ça ressemble à un front syndical mais
l'union sacrée présente quelques failles
nicole notât de la cfdt et à l'un d'eux
le de la cftc s'affiche plus modérée
leur credo discuter pour réformer c'est
une histoire vieille de cent ans comme
le syndicalisme les durs face aux
modérés larbitre c'est la base rarement
modéré souvent très dures toutes
tendances confondues